[Musique]
Isabelle Saborta, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
On vous reçoit dans votre dans le cadre
de votre domaine d'activité, le
journalisme, l'agriculture, la santé.
Comment ça va ?
Bah, ça va pas mal. On est bien chez
vous en fait. Je me sens plutôt bien.
Pourquoi en fait ? Bah parce que vous
êtes bizarre quand même. Vous nous
contactez bizarrement. Non, je j'ai ce
coup de fil était lunaire. J'ai bien
aimé hein, mais c'était il fallait être
un peu à l'instant à l'instinct de
savoir que ça allait bien se passer.
Non, ça c'est pas ma fille. Non. Bon là
on a le nom de son amant mais bon.
Attention les gars, il fallait pas
laisser ton téléphone demain.
Tu es sûr que il faut pas que je réponds
? C'est marrant. Non non.
Non.
Donc désolé pour ce petit aparté.
Euh c'est c'est
C'est bien. Donc c'était lunaire et le
début de l'interview aussi.
Comment on a fait pour vous contacter ?
Alors comment on a fait pour te
contacter ?
Mais je sais pas c'était tu m'as appelé,
tu m'as dit je sais pas qui je tu m'as
tutoyé direct donc on peut se tutoyer
parce qu'on se connaît pas mais on se
tutoie. Tu m'as dit je sais pas qui tu
es, je vois même pas qui tu es mais on
est des hackur et on a vu ton nom
émerger dans la communauté. Donc tu es
qui ? Et j'ai moi j'ai bien j'ai bien
aimé en fait. Ça m'a ça m'a apparu une
bonne entrée en matière qui m'a bien
fait marrer en fait.
Donc tu es qui succintement ?
Je suis journaliste. Euh je me suis
spécialisée en fait dans les questions
effectivement euh d'agroalimentaire, de
d'agriculture
notamment parce que j'ai écrit une
première enquête qui s'appelait livre
noir de l'agriculture qui m'a valu
d'être assez mal vu. C'est un euphémisme
par le syndicat majoritaire de
l'agriculture qui est la FNSE. Et voilà.
Après, j'avais fait un autre, j'en ai
commis un autre sur le 20 sur le
bordelet notamment qui s'appelle Vino
Business qui m'a valu quelques quelques
petits procès avec des cadors du
bordelet et puis voilà. Et en fait, bon
bah j'ai euh je je tendance à dire que
les lobby font leur travail de lobby et
que généralement c'est pas pour notre
bien que l'industrie agroalimentaire
fait du business et tout ça ne plaît pas
aux gens alors qu'au fond c'est pas un
happening d'ment de se dire que voilà
ils font plus du lobbying et du pognon
que de s'occuper de notre santé quoi.
Les procès, c'était pourquoi
le procès le pire là ? Donc celui sur le
bord de lait, c'était le numéro enfin
c'est c'est un mec qui s'appelle Hubert
de Boire de la forêt qui a un château
qui s'appelle Angélius qui a un premier
grand cru classé A.
Du bon pinard,
c'est du très bon vin effectivement. Et
en fait effectivement, j'expliquais que
pour le classement de Saint-Émilion, il
avait été jugé parti que ça faisait des
si tu veux de faire finalement le
classement à ta main, ça faisait des
plusvalues potentielles sur le foncier
qui était juste mirobolante, sur les
bouteilles qui étaient pareilles et que
comme en plus et de façon tout à fait
fortuite comme tu l'imagines, il est
également consultant d'une bonne partie
des gens qui cherchaient à être classé,
il en avait fait un bon business model
et que quand même ce business model si
tu veux sur un classement qui
normalement est fait par l'IN O,
c'est-à-dire l'Institut national de
l'origine et de la qualité, c'est-à-dire
au fond une émanation du ministère de
l'agriculture. Donc si tu veux que les
gens fassent du pognon, je suis pas
contre, pourquoi pas ? Si tu veux qu'il
soit jugé parti, pourquoi pas ? Mais que
l'État soit là-dedans en train de
cautionner ça, si tu veux, ça c'est
juste quelque chose qui était pas
tolérable. Et donc comme quand même dans
ces questions du bordelet et des grands
pinards en en général, euh on est quand
même dans une dans une court tisannerie
totale. C'est-à-dire que c'est vrai que
la enfin je veux pas me faire des amis
mais enfin ils m'aime déjà pas donc un
peu plus un peu moins c'est pas grave
mais c'est vrai que si tu veux tous ces
grands dégustateurs de vin que sont les
journalistes spécialisés ils sont
tellement contents d'être invités dans
ces très beaux châteaux et on les
comprend parce qu'on est bien dans ces
dans ces grands châteaux.
Catering, c'est ça on appelle ça du
cattering.
Ouais. Je sais pas ce que c'est le
cining. Je te dis ouais mais j'en sais
rien. C'est quoi
manger des petits fours gratos ?
Mais ouais bah c'est ça. Mais tu sais
parce que tu parles anglais. Moi je suis
trop côtoyer le bourgeois.
Ben c'est ça aller côtoyer le bourgeois.
Et en fait Mais oui mais c'est c'est une
cour en fait. C'est une cour et donc
quand tu es dans la cour il faut être
bien avec le roi et pour être bien avec
le roi même si tu connais ses secrets tu
ne les divulgues pas. Et effectivement
moi je
dans la même loge.
Alors ça je pense effectivement si tu
veux que ça ça faisait partie du truc
mais j'avoue que j'ai pas creusé la
question de la franc-maçonnerie. Oui, il
y a une franc-maçonnerie très forte euh
à Bordeaux. Un Ouais, à Bordeaux. Mais
je me suis pas posé plus que là que ça
cette question. Je trouve qu'il y avait
déjà suffisamment à faire si tu veux sur
tout le côté effectivement bon un
organisme d'état, comment ils mettent le
grappin dessus et comment ils arrivent à
faire du pognon avec sans sans mettre
les francmaçons là-dedans. Mais de fait,
je pense que on aurait pu le faire. Mais
je l'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas creusé
cette question. Je t'avoue franchement
les choses.
Raconte-moi cette histoire de tour à
Chabli en plein milieu de du vignoble.
Bah ça si tu veux c'était encore des
idées à la con hein parce qu' en fait il
y a pas c'est c'est tu vois en France on
a quand même pas de grand-chose qui
marche de feu de Dieu mais il se trouve
que notre vin ça marche très très bien
et qu'effectivement si tu veux au lieu
de se dire bah le vin ça marche bien on
va les soutenir on va les aider si tu
veux ils avaient eu cette idée de faire
une espèce d'usine habitume au plein
cœur du vignoble
bourguignon si tu veux et et je et bon
donc du coup je me suis battu on les a
fait reculer bon ils vont la faire
ailleurs hein faut quand même pas rêver
si tu veux, ça va pas arrêter. Donc ils
vont le faire sans doute dans des terres
où il y a plutôt des éleveurs laitiers
que que du que du chabli. Mais malgré
tout, si tu veux que l'idée leur germe
dans la tête de faire une une usine
habitume au cœur d'un des vignobles les
plus prestigieux au monde sans se poser
la question de ce que ça va donner comme
image à l'international de sans se poser
la question de de des résidus que ça
pourrait mettre dans le vin, c'est
quelque chose qui me fascine. Voilà.
Mais enfin, tu sais en fait euh il y a
ça, il y a 50000 500 quand je te dis
50000, il y a un milliard de conneries à
la minute. Parce que je suis désolée, je
suis très grossière hein. Ça c'est un
vrai problème. C'estd que généralement
je fais attention là, je suis je suis un
peu à l'aise. Donc euh voilà.
Euh c'est pour ça aussi que j'avais fait
foot la P tu sais, j'avais fait un tour
de France en fait de tous les mecs qui
font hyper bien et qui sont en kikquiné
en permanence. Et et là, tu te rends
compte qu'en France, autant tu vois, on
peut être faible avec l'effort, hein,
quand tu as affaire à l'industrie
agroalimentaire, quand tu as affaire euh
comment dire au aux grandes surfaces et
tout ça, alors là c'est vas-y que je
t'offre une usine, vas-y que je te je te
je te fasse du foncier pas cher et
cetera. Par contre effectivement, quand
on
Non, c'est pas mon chéri là, c'est ma
fille, j'espère.
Non non, c'est ton chéri.
Ah bah écoute, c'est mon chéri et c'est
pas grave. Et donc euh
je crois qu'il est en direct avec nous
parce qu'il vient de raccrocher là.
Et donc
et donc et donc pourquoi je j'étais
partie sur et j'étais parti sur les gens
qu'on nous enquiquine en permanence et
donc si tu veux tu as des tu as des tu
as des par exemple un mec qui s'appelle
Alexandre Bain qui fait un vin
magnifique
à à Puis et qui s'est retrouvé
Ouais. et qui s'est retrouvé à à avoir
une brigade de la végétation
concurrentielle. C'estàd une brigade de
la hauteur de l'herbe. C'estàd qu'il y a
des gens qui sont venus qui ont mesuré
l'herbe et qui ont décidé que l'herbe
était trop haute pour que ça reste du
bon vin en appellation d'origine
contrôlée. Par contre, les mecs qui
utilisent des pesticides, des
désherbants si tu veux, eux, on
considère que c'est pas un problème et
que euh il y a, tu vois, ça ne gêne pas
pour l'appellation d'origine contrôlée.
Et donc, j'avais fait un Tour de France
de tous ces mecs qui font bien. Et en
fait, ça s'est passé parce que quand
j'avais fait mon livre noir de
l'agriculture, il y a des il y a des des
agriculteurs qui sont venus me voir et
qui m'ont dit "Écoute, c'est très bien,
tu dénonces les euh les les salot en
gros." Mais ce qui serait bien
maintenant, c'est quand même que euh tu
vois à quel point nous qui faisons bien,
on nous met des bâtons dans les roues en
permanence parce qu'on fait bien. Et
c'est vrai que juste ces gens-là sont
des héros quotidien si tu veux. C'estàd
que moi au début quand il m'envoyait euh
par mail euh tout ce que leur demandait
l'administration, au début, je croyais
que c'était des blagues, tu vois. Je
veux dire, il y a un mec qui voulait
pouvoir vendre juste son poulet à la
cantine d'en face, mais il a mis 2 ans à
avoir les autorisations parce que son
ventilateur était trop petit, trop gros,
mal placé, parce que le clou pour
accrocher la pelle, pour ramasser les
plumes était pas à la bonne hauteur,
parce que mais des trucs mais que tu
imagines même pas. Et donc ce mec s'est
battu pendant 2 ans avec en changeant de
place son ventilateur, en mettant son
cou lou un petit peu plus comme si et
moi je trouve que ces gens sont des
héros quotidiens tout ça pour
qu'effectivement pouvoir livrer la
cantine d'en face.
Tu comprends aussi les gens qui se
battent pour les normes sanitaires qui
se battent pour tout ça ? Moi, je
comprends très bien les gens qui se
battent pour les normes sanitaires. Si
je me bats pour les normes sanitaires,
le vrai problème, c'est qu'aujourd'hui,
si tu veux, l'industrie agroalimentaire
a réussi un holdup génial, c'est-à-dire
de dire au fond, les mecs, tout ce qui
compte, tout ce qui est la gestion du
sanitaire, ça va être nous ça. On va
dicctter des normes. Et ces normes en
fait, c'est extraordinaire. Il y a que
l'industrie agroalimentaire qui soit
capable de les respecter. Et tu vois ces
normes sanitaires, on est en plein
dedans, tu vois. Sauf que regarde quand
tu as l'affaire lactalis qui explose.
Regarde quand il y a cette histoire de
de lait contaminé pour les bébés. Bon,
transparence
là à ce moment-là, on se rend compte que
c'est du bullshit ces normes sanitaires
si tu veux que comme on est dans
l'autocontrôle de l'industrie
agroalimentaire par elle-même, et ben
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Et ben
d'autocontrôle foireux, on autocontrôle
foireux, ils sont toujours blancs comme
neige alors que ils savent que le lait
n'est pas n'est pas net. Tu vois ce que
je veux dire ? et on est là-dedans. Et
par contre entre-temps, on aura fait
crever tous les petits producteurs de
l'écru en leur disant "Non mais vous
êtes jamais dans les clous." Tu vois ?
Donc moi ce qui m'embête c'est que sous
prétexte que soit-disant c'est pour
sauver notre santé, on est en train de
faire crever tout ce qu'on fait de nuit
en France de petits producteurs que
notre santé en même temps elle est pas
préservée. Parce que regarde le fiprony
dans les œufs. Non mais le fiprony dans
les œufs, c'est pas
Ouais mais c'était c'était pas c'était
pas des c'était pas des petits
producteurs.
Un insecticide, c'est un antipou. Donc
si tu veux Et pourquoi il y a besoin
d'antipou ? parce que les poules sont
tellement collées les unes aux autres
qu'il y a des parasites parce qu'on est
dans des univers concentrationnaires.
Pourquoi il y a autant besoin de de
médicaments et de comment dire
d'antibiotiques dans les dans les
élevages porin ? Mais parce que c'est
des c'est des univers
concentrationnaires. Donc si tu veux, on
crée la pathologie en ayant des élevages
concentrationnaires et après si tu veux
euh on crée le problème et après on
érige la norme sanitaire en disant "Non,
mais on va tout résoudre.
l'élevage, la grippe avière, c'était la
même histoire. La grippe avière, on nous
a dit "Ah non mais attendez, la grippe
avière, le vrai problème c'est les
animaux sauvages." Est-ce que tu as vu
quand tu te baladais l'année dernière
des oiseaux sauvages qui te tombaient
sur la tête ? Ça te tombait de rue sur
la tête ? Non, ça tit jamais tombé de ru
sur la tête parce que ça n'a jamais été
le problème. Ça n'a jamais été les
animaux, ils se posent, ils vont faire
coucou aux animaux d'élevage, ils se
transmettent leur maladie. Non mais tu
vois si vraiment ça avait pas été un
bullshit d'enfer ça tu vois ça devrait
nous tomber les oiseaux devraient tomber
tu vois de rue du ciel sauf que c'est
pas ça qui s'est passé parce qu'en fait
le vrai problème c'était encore une fois
l'univers concentrationnaire
c'est-à-dire qu'on a segmenté le
l'élevage de canard il y a ceux qui font
net il y a ceux qui les poussent jusqu'à
3 semaines il y a ceux qui prennent le
relais après. Après, tu as fait des
usines à canard un petit peu partout
hein qui sont séparés de centaines de
kilomètres et là oh c'est bizarre, il y
a des élevages où il y a des épidémies
si tu veux. Et après du coup, tu as le
ministre de l'agriculture de l'époque,
rappelle-toi Stéphane Le Fol qui nous a
dit "Non mais pour se sortir de ça les
mecs, on a la solution, faut éradiquer
tous les petits élevages de proximité.
Donc si tu veux, moi je n'ai rien contre
les normes sanitaires, je les défends.
Ce que je voudrais c'est qu'on arrête de
nous prendre pour des cons en fait.
Tu as été formé par Jean-Pierre Coff ?
Ouais. raconte un peu.
Alors Jean-Pierre Cof, c'était assez
génial parce que ça s'est passé à peu
près notre rencontre à peu près comme
avec toi. C'est-à-dire que en fait un
jour, un soir comme ça, il m'appelle
avec sa voix qui était reconnaissable
entre 1000 en disant
"Bonjour, c'est Jean-Pierre Cof, tu vois
?" Et et je dis je me suis dit "C'est un
pote qui se fout de ma gueule en fait."
Et je dis "Ouais." Et il me dit "Ben,
j'ai lu tes papiers dans Marianne et
j'adore ce que tu fais. Est-ce que tu
veux est-ce que tu veux travailler pour
moi ? Est-ce que tu veux être mon aèigre
parce qu'en fait c'est comme ça qu'on
dit. Euh et donc effectivement, j'ai
commencé euh oui enfin mon ghost writer
si tu préfères et en fait c'est comme ça
que j'ai commencé à travailler pour lui
et il m'a dit "Mais écoute toi tu es
quand même qu'une sale petite parisienne
ce qui est parfaitement vrai et il va
falloir que tu ailles partout et donc il
m'a envoyé partout et j'ai été partout
dans tous les élevages
concentrationnaires porsin et ça pue.
J'ai été vraiment partout partout
partout et ça m'a beaucoup formé et il a
été vraiment Ouais, il a été vraiment
enfin ça m'a beaucoup plu parce que si
tu veux moi j'avais fait un doctorat de
sciences politique, je voulais faire du
journalisme. Quand tu rentres dans le
journalisme si tu veux, il y a entre
guillemets euh les ce qu'on considère
être les matières nobles. Et les
matières nobles, c'est quoi ? C'est
journalistes politiques, c'est tu vois.
Et en fait moi quand je suis arrivée,
j'avais pas de piston, j'avais rien. Et
donc du coup j'ai j'ai été tapée un
petit peu partout à toutes les portes et
le seul qui m'est permis de travailler
pour lui c'est Jean-François Cann et
donc à Marianne et Jean-François m'a dit
"De toute façon, il reste qu'un truc ici
que les gens veulent pas faire, c'est la
consommation. Est-ce que tu veux ?" Et
j'ai dit "Vas-y, j'y vais, j'y vais." Et
je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait, il y
avait rien de plus politique que ça.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait ce qu'on bouffe,
la façon dont on cultive la terre, ce
qu'on fait de notre foncier, ce qu'on
fait de nos mères, ce qu'on fait de tu
vois de l'écologie et cetera en général,
c'est il y a rien de plus politique en
fait. C'est le seul combat qui mérite
d'être mené aujourd'hui pour moi si tu
veux. Et ça ça n'intéressait pas les
journalistes qui trouvaient ça que ça
sentait un peu trop fort lavage, que
c'était pas assez chic et que ça
permettait pas de briller dans les dans
les dîners mondins. Comme il se trouve
que j'en ai rien à [__] de briller
dans les dîners mondinants, ça s'est
très bien passé et ça m'a beaucoup plu.
Voilà, il y a plus rien à dire. Je me
casse en fait. Non non, j'étais j'étais
en train de t'imaginer au cul de la
vache en loupboutin.
Et ben écoute, je l'ai toujours fait
parce que en fait je trouve que ce
serait me tu vois je c'est c'est marrant
parce que c'est ce que je raconte dans
mon roman. C'estàd que en fait, si tu
veux quand j'ai commencé à être sur le
terrain, euh je me suis dit est-ce que
je commence parce que j'étais quand même
pas mal aussi dans les milieux écolo et
c'est vrai que dans les milieux écolos,
il y a quand même une espèce de
propension à à pas se maquiller pour les
meufs, à pas, tu vois, avoir des des
vêtements, tu vois, pas trop branchés,
machin et cetera. Et je me suis dit,
est-ce que pour me fondre dans le décor,
j'arrête les talons, je me maquille
plus, j'ai l'air moins d'une [__]
quoi. Tu vois que comme je suis,
ouais, enfin un petit peu quand même
plus. Et en fait, je me suis dit que ce
serait vraiment finalement d'abord me
travestir, ne plus être moi-même et au
fond, je suis ce que je suis, tu vois.
Je suis une parisienne, je suis comme
ça. Je je vais pas arriver déguisé pour
aller sur des terrains où les gens sont
sont écolos pour leur montrer que je
suis vraiment écolo. J'ai pas besoin
d'avoir un déguisement pour ça. Mais
c'est vrai que ça a toujours été un
truc, tu à chaque fois je que je partais
en reportage et que j'avais mes petits
mes petits échantillons de parfum d'une
grande marque, tu vois, et je me dis "Ah
quand même, je je" Et j'allais chercher
dans la poubelle les
emballages pour pas que ça se voit parce
que j'avais un peu honte d'être une, tu
vois, bah de pas être parfaitement.
Après après ce petit entraînement pour
te faire le palais, parce que tu as dû
te faire le palais aussi au passage.
Non.
Ouais.
C'était pas un peu tard pour te faire le
palais ? Je t'emmerde. C'est pas ça
qu'il faut dire. Non
non.
Si. Euh
le palais. Quel âge tu as ? 41 ans.
Ouais, j'ai 41 ans.
Combien tu gagnes ?
Écoute, cette année, je gagne bien ma
vie. Cette année, je dois être à 4000
balles par mois.
Nette.
Ouais.
Combien tu as vendu de bouquin ?
Alors, ça dépend desquels. Le livre noir
de l'agriculture, on en a vendu plus de
100000.
Vin Business, j'ai dû en vendre 25000.
Foutez-nous la P400. à peu près.
Est-ce que ça a eu un impact sur les
politiques qu'une petite nana comme toi
euh pas trop mal prêtée commence à à
polir sa pierre autour de sujets qui
sont touchy ? Est-ce que les politiques
te regardent toujours de haut ou tu
commences à être un petit peu
dérangeante ? Est-ce qu'il commence à
écouter tes propositions ? Est-ce que tu
formules des propositions dans tes
bouquins ?
Écoute, je vais te raconter je vais te
raconter mon entretien avec Stéphane
Lefol, l'ancien ministre de
l'agriculture. C'était lunaire donc
c'était pour foutous la paix. J'avais
été le voir. J'étais avec toutes les
trucs, tu sais, qui allaiit de travers,
la brigade de la hauteur de l'herbe, le
t tous les trucs d'imment que j'avais
trouvé, quoi. Donc, je suis allée voir
son cabinet qui m'a reçu très gentiment
et cetera et cetera et euh je vois le
folle qui me dit donc son cabinet à qui
je dis il y a ça, il y a ça, il y a ça.
Ils prennent des notes, il ah ouais, il
y a ça. Tu es sûr ? Je oui, je suis
sûre. Il y a ça, il y a ça, il y a ça.
Ah ouais, tu es sûr ? Ouais, ouais, je
suis sûre. Donc voilà. Incroyable quand
même. En fait, tuattends pas qu'il te
disent incroyable. Tu attends juste
qu'il disent c'est inadmissible, je m'en
occupe demain quoi. Tu vois juste j'ai
l'impression de d'être Martine Martine
chez les chez chez les politiques en
train de leur apprendre comment ça se
passait. Bon, OK. Et donc si tu veux
finalement l'entretien se passe. Donc je
vois qu'ils prennent des notes que
effectivement ils me disent qu'ils en
viennent pas, que ça existe. Donc
j'étais un peu désespérée et je vois le
fol qui me tient un discours sur la
qualité, le machin, le truc mais
exactement ce que j'avais envie
d'entendre. Mais tu mais tu peux pas
savoir vraiment j'en aurais eu les
larmes aux yeux. L'agriculture c'est si
c'est ça. Je fais OK. Et après il allait
présenter sa loi au Sénat. Et donc je
dis "Ah bah tiens, je vais aller vous
écouter aussi au Sénat là juste après."
Et là il me tui direct et il me dit "Ah
mais laisse tomber, te fais pas chier,
je vais juste aller parler devant deux
trois connards, t'inquiète pas, je vais
avoir à deux trois connards et moi je
vais venir vous écouter." Et là le mec
est là-bas et là il dit exactement
l'inverse, mais l'inverse mais mot pour
mot de tout ce qu'il m'avait dit quand
on était face- à face. Mais l'inverse.
Mais oui, il faut arrêter de se faire
chier avec l'écologie. Enfin, il disait
pas comme ça parce qu'on était au Cénar
mais il faut qu'il y ait des
installations qu'on facilite les
installations de porcherie industrielle
qu'on fasse pareil pour la vieulture,
qu'on fasse pareil pour les gros
élevages laitiers. Et là, si tu veux,
j'ai eu comme l'impression que le sol se
dérobait sous mes pass. C'estd que je
pense pas être une ravie de la crèche et
je pense pas, tu vois, être né de la
dernière pluie. Malgré ça, si tu veux ce
truc de certains politiques et je les
mets pas tous dans le même panier, il y
a des gens hyper courageux, voilà, mais
que tu vois de te tenir le discours que
tu as envie d'entendre et de tenir le
discours inverse devant une autre, tu
vois, communauté pour reprendre vos,
c'est un truc que je comprends pas si tu
veux parce que parce que voilà parce que
c'est pas possible, tu vois. Et c'est et
je pense qu'on en crève. Je pense que si
le premier parti de France en France
c'est l'abstentionnisme et le second
c'est comment ils appellent maintenant
le Front National, je m'en rappelle plus
là, enfin le Rassemblement national. Euh
si tu veux c'est pas pour rien. C'est
qu'au fond on a perdu, tu vois la
confiance dans nos politiques parce que
nos journalistes aussi. Non
mais oui mais mais on a on n pas
franchement. Il y a un journalisme de
cours en France aussi. Il faut quand
même dire les choses. Je veux dire, il y
a C'est vrai que tu vois, moi je me
rappelle que quand j'ai sorti mon vino
business,
vraiment si tu veux c'était un truc de
fou. C'estàd que les mecs m'appelaient,
il disent vraiment super ton bouquin,
génial, on a vachement aimé. En revanche
là, tu vois le supplément 20 c'est tant
de milliers d'euros pour le journal donc
on en parlera pas si tu veux. Espèce de
truc d'omerta parce qu'en fait si tu
veux c'est le pognon. Le pognon, c'est
ça. Donc si tu veux, on en crève de ça
aussi. C'est qu'entre les politiques euh
avec lesquels il faut pas se croisser
parce que bon, c'est quand même chique
d'être bien vu par les politiques. Il y
a quand même ça. Euh les mecs qui
tiennent les cordons de la bourse, euh
tu te dis mais euh bon mais sinon euh
voilà. Et moi je vais dire un truc,
c'est moi c'est un truc de c'est pour ça
que j'ai une espèce de vision un peu
mercenaire de mon passage dans les
médias. C'est que à chaque fois je suis
je comme je suis une plutôt une bonne
cliente, je me fais démarcher par des
radios commerciales et à chaque fois je
me demande dans combien de temps je vais
me faire virer si tu veux parce que je
dure 6 mois, 1 an, un an et demi, 2 ans
et au bout d'un moment les annonceurs
disent c'est pas possible, elle fait
trop chier, pas possible. Donc je finis
toujours par me faire virer. Au début,
je trouvais ça très triste. Maintenant,
je m'en fous complètement. C'est-à-dire
que j'attends de me faire virer. Je
sais, je retrouverai quelqu'un parce que
de toute façon le système entre
guillemets a besoin de jambes comme moi
pour montrer que tu vois ils sont libres
au bout d'un moment il font "On a beau
être libre là, elle fait vraiment chier
et ils me foutent dehors et je trouve
d'autres qui ont besoin de montrer
qu'ils sont libres jusqu'à ce que je les
fasse trop chier et c'est comme ça."
Voilà
les prétextes quand ils te foutent à la
porte c'est quoi ?
En fait, généralement si tu vois, au
début il y a des gens qui sont caches,
tu vois, gen Jean-Jacques Bourdin, il te
dit qu'il m'a vraiment tenu par les
cheveux pendant des des mois et des mois
si tu veux, il y a un moment, il m'a dit
"C'est compliqué les annonceurs et lui,
il a été cache bourdin, il a été cache
direct." Il a même pas fait semblant.
Euh c'est là que moi j'aime bien chez ce
mec-là. Euh et après les autres, il te
proposent des trucs que tu veux pas
faire. Ils disent "Non, c'est sympa tous
tes trucs sur euh euh tu vois
l'industrie agimentaire, que tu tapes
sur Carrefour, tout ça. Si tu pouvais
plutôt nous faire tu vois euh un
comparatif des déodorants le matin, euh
on trouvait ça super. Donc une fois,
deux fois, trois fois, il te propose, tu
vois, et tu déclines pignement le
comparatif de déodorant que tu as pas
tellement envie de faire et à la 4rième
fois, ils disent "Non, mais si je veux
pas faire le comparatif de déodorant, on
va pas pouvoir continuer, tu vois." Donc
en fait ça se passe comme ça. Mais je
sais que quand j'en suis au comparatif
de déodorant, c'est qu'ils veulent
vraiment me [__] dehors.
Tes collègues, ils sont solidairire avec
toi ?
Ouais. Moi, si tu veux, bah après si tu
veux le truc, moi je moi je cracherai
pas sur les autres si tu veux. Je veux
dire euh moi j'ai toujours été euh
je sais pas comment dire, je
normale.
Non, je sais pas si je suis normale.
Mais je sais pas si je suis normale.
Respectant la charte de Munique.
Non, mais je veux dire, je
C'est quoi la charte de Munique ?
Je sais pas. Tu as une carte de presse ?
Ouais.
Depuis combien de temps ?
Je sais pas. 10 ans, 15 ans et je sais
pas ce que c'est. C'est mal. C'est très
mal.
Bon ben je suis désolé.
Ah ouais c'est c'est comme c'est
l'équivalent du sulfite dans le pinard.
Ouais bah tant pis. Écoute le la charte
des droits et devoirs du journaliste.
Ah oui bah écoute je sais pas moi je je
pense que je l'ai même jamais lu. Ah
ouais
mais euh
c'est mal. Je te jure que c'est mal. Mal
c'est très mal. Mais mais là, tu vas
prendre cher pendant encore tr qu4
d'heure.
Mais bon bah tant pis. Mais mais mais je
pense que instinctivement, je pense que
je toujours été à peu près réglot.
Maintenant, si tu veux que mes petits
camarades entre guillemets et des
angoisses euh sur leur boulot, sur leur
avenir et tout ça, je cracherai pas.
Tu vois, je cracherai pas là-dessus
parce que je veux dire de fait moi j'ai
je comprends qu'il y a une soumission
consentie.
Écoute, de fait c'est casse- gueule si
tu veux. Quand je défonce Mot Fonten
noir à France Télévision, tu vois ce que
je veux dire ? Parce que tu lui as mis.
Ouais, je lui ai mis. Je lui ai mis.
D'accord. OK. Oh et puis c'était
suffisamment court pour faire une tug
life mé d'anthologie.
Bon d'accord.
Alors mais vous l'avez pas lu mon livre.
Si si j'ai tout lu.
Bon mais sauf que si tu veux je sais que
je vais me faire virer genre je sais
enfin je me fais je vais partir avec
Pananache avant de me faire virer. Donc
je me fais virer au fond hein parce que
je pars avec Panache juste avant de me
faire humilier. Donc si tu veux je sais
ce que je vais faire. Sauf que si tu
veux malgré tout et je moi je pense pas
faire pleurer dans les chaumières parce
que vraiment j'ai je fais ce que j'aime
euh j'ai la liberté de de ton donc je tu
vois je sais quand même que je vais
avoir 4 5 mois compliqué financièrement.
Donc si tu veux après euh c'est mon
choix d'avoir ces 4 5 mois compliqués
financièrement que les gens aient pas
envie de les avoir les comprends aussi
tu vois parce que pourquoi ils font
journaliste ?
Euh ben j'en sais rien mais si tu veux
moi je pense que j'aurais été partout,
j'aurais été pareil. Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ?
Tu connais Denis Robert ?
Ouais.
Ça te fait penser à quoi Denis Robert ?
Bah pourquoi ça me fait penser à quoi ?
Qu'est-ce que tu veux dire ? Que tu
penses que justement procédon les
procédures billon et tout le teint toin
mais qu'est-ce que tu veux ? C'est sûr,
c'est sûr, c'est sûr.
Il faut pas plus de journalistes comme
vous. Tête brûlée, instinctive,
sanguine,
un peu folle,
un peu givrée. Ouais, je sais pas, je
sais pas, je sais pas parce que
moi, je te dirais oui. Et mais si tu
veux, c'est enfin ce que je veux te
dire, c'est que au fond, je veux pas
avoir l'air de la nana qui se prend pour
quelque chose qu'elle n'est pas, le
prochevalier, tu vois ce que je veux
dire ?
Tu vois ? Oui, je le suis un peu de
fait, mais si tu veux, je veux pas je
veux pas avoir l'air de juger mes petits
camarades.
Pourquoi tu tombes dans le misérabilisme
de l'impuissance ?
Ah non, mais je suis pas moi je pense
qu'on est puissant. C'est que je moi je
suis pas du tout dans le misérabilisme
de l'impuissance. Moi je pense qu'on est
puissant. Je pense que les quand quand
les quand les politiques veulent être
courageux, tu vois par exemple, je pense
à Joël Labé, le sénateur Joël Labé qui
se bat comme un chien. Je pense à
Brigitte Alin sénatrice aussi. Je Il y a
des gens quand ils se battent ça député,
ça marche, tu vois. Donc je pense pas
qu'on soit impuissant. Je pense juste
que euh c'est plus casse- gueule de
d'ouvrir sa gueule. Voilà. Et que
certains préfèrent ne pas le faire. Je
les comprends. Je te dis pas que je
ferai pareil. Je te dis je comprends.
C'est vrai que si tu veux euh je pense
que je ferme je te fermerai davantage ma
gueule. J'aurais peut-être aujourd'hui
mon émission à la télé, mon émission à
la radio. Je gagnerai sans doute cinq
fois mieux ma vie qu'aujourd'hui et
cetera et cetera. Mais moi, je trouve
que ce qui compte dans la vie, c'est pas
de gagner sa vie comme un dingue. Je
trouve que je la gagne très bien. C'est
de pouvoir être libre, libre de dire ce
qu'on a envie de dire, de d'enquêter sur
ce qu'on a envie d'enquêter et surtout
libre de de construire un avenir pour
nos enfants. Parce que tu vois, c'est ça
qui compte en fait. Qu'est-ce qui va
rester à la fin, hein ? Il va rester
quoi si tous ces tous ces gens là qui
sont contents qu'on leur donne des
breloques là, des légions d'honneur, des
machins des trucs, pour quel honneur
d'ailleurs ? On se demande. Je veux
dire, à la fin, qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qu' va rester ? qui va rester l'état de
la planète qu'on va donner à nos
enfants, la santé pour nos enfants, pour
les générations futures, le reste, ça
n'a aucun intérêt. Mais par contre, je
comprends qu'à court terme, si tu veux,
si tu as envie d'être bien vu par
Macron, si tu as envie d'être invité par
Nicolas Hullo, si tu as envie, faut pas
être moi. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Faut pas être moi. Et et voilà. Bon, il
se trouve que j'ai même pas besoin de me
forcer parce que tout ça ne m'intéresse
pas. Mais si ça m'intéressait, je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens que ça
intéresse, je comprends qu'il ne le
fassent pas. Je pense qu'effectivement,
il faut mieux être un petit peu un toit
en dessous. ou avaler des sabres.
Oui, mais je pense pas que ça leur
coûte, j'ai envie de te dire.
Je pense qu'ils le font avec, tu vois,
le réflex de le réflexe de déglission.
Mais voilà, je pense que voilà, je pense
que et après pourquoi pas
je veux dire, il y a toujours eu des
courtisans quand tu relis les mémoires
de Saint-Simon, tu vois. Je veux dire,
il y a toujours eu des gens qui qui
faisaient des petits pattes d'eux devant
les marquis, devant les devant les rois,
devant les machins. Bon ben
qui serait pas tant que les journalistes
fassent un peu le ménage derrière ceux
qui font des petits pat de
Ah mais je pense que les ceux qui font
les PES de sont quand même la majorité
hein. Donc
[Applaudissements]
ça me paraît compliqué ce que tu nous
proposes.
Peut vous aider.
Ah non mais moi je suis à fond hein.
Mais si tu veux je pense que c'est
compliqué. Je pense que si tu veux de
fait quand on se retrouve
tu vois là ce ce midi, on avait on
recevait un mec don j'ai oublié le nom
d'ailleurs, un navigateur sur Europe et
et le mec t'explique longuement que il
lutte pour la planète, le machin, le
truc et tout ça, mais que par contre il
est climatosceptique.
Bon, une fois, deux fois, trois fois,
puis arrive la minute où je dois parler
et là bon, je le défonce hein. Je lui
dis que il explique que il a toujours
été mal conseillé que machin que truc et
je lui dis sans doute vous avez été mal
conseillé une fois de plus. Et il y
avait une autre nana, une autre
navigatrice qui nous expliquait à quel
point c'était extraordinaire le pôle,
les pôles et machin et que du coup
maintenant elle était devenue euh elle
était devenue comment on dit en fait
organisatrice de voyage. Et je me suis
dit en fait et si tu veux, je leur ai
dit bon ben voilà en fait vous êtes
devant un bon business model et l'un et
l'autre bon bah on se réjouit si tu veux
mais c'est vrai que j'ai bien vu si tu
veux ils ont l'habitude ils m'ont prise
pour ça mais si tu veux que j'ai
tendance à mettre les les pieds dans le
plat ça y est c'est la maison c'est ma
fille
ah bah tout va bien tu sais qu'elle est
bien arrivé voilà non et puis maintenant
on peut couper le portable j'ai envie de
te dire du moment que ma fille rentré
jeéressant
non c'est bien là je crois que tuas tu
as eu un petit aper Voà là, j'ai eu un
scoop. Mais
c'est pas bien ça.
On peut être un hackur. On peut être un
hackur au grand cœur, j'ai envie de te
dire. Non,
on est au grand cœur, on a rien dit. Tu
as vu ? Bon, alors on va changer de
sujet histoire de te permettre de
pouvoir respirer un peu. La pâque, ça te
parle ?
Oui. Bah, ça me fait bien respirer. Tu
as raison.
Mais ouais, ça c'est un sujet léger,
j'ai envie de te dire. un sujet pou
ça passe tout seul tu
écoute écoute
c'est marrant parce que là moi j'ai j'ai
un peu en fait là tu vois je j'ai mon
grand âge qui revient et je commence
non mais je commence à être tu vois il y
a un moment où j'ai j'ai presque envie
de là j'ai vraiment envie de gueuler en
fait si tu veux parce que de fait
ça fait quand même 15 ans que je répète
la même chose. Ça fait 15 ans que je dis
[__] on a entre 9 et 10 milliards
chaque année sur l'agriculture.
au lieu de le mettre sur ce qu'on fait
de mieux si tu veux, on le met sur ce
qu'on fait de pire hein. Et après, je ne
te parle même pas des dommages
collatéraux que nous payons tous avec
nos impôts. La dépollution, l'eau,
c'est dingue. Si tu veux, c'est un
système vraiment de Shad, tu sais he
moins tu vois, on a vraiment
l'impression qu'on va pas s'arrêter de
pomper. Moi c'est un truc que j'arrive
pas à comprendre et c'est tellement
facile, tu vois. Là, je je suis devenue
éditrice aussi chez Fard et j'ai édité
un mec qui est génial, qui s'appelle
Benoît Bito qui a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle paysan résistant. Et là le
mec, il t'explique comment dans une ce
qui était une exploitation, par que
j'aime pas le terme mais ce qui était
une exploitation qui fonctionnait avec
du maïs irigué, ce qui fonctionnait avec
des bâtiments surdimensionnés, qui
fonctionnaiit avec plein de pesticides,
plein de subventions pour faire de la
merde, pour dire les choses comme elles
sont si tu veux. On pouvait en quelques
années, 3 4 5 ans maximum en faire un
petit bijou d'agroécologie où tu remets
des races locales, où tu laisses tomber
le maïs irrigué, où tu fais tes semences
et il gagne de l'argent et ça fonctionne
et il y a plus une prise pareil sur la
flotte sur et tu te dis mais si c'est si
facile,
pourquoi on le fait pas ? Alors ça
c'était quand j'étais encore un peu
gourde, je me dis ah mais c'est si
facile, pourquoi on le fait pas ? Et
entre-temps, je me suis très facile,
mais le vrai problème, c'est que le
système actuel, si tu veux, bah pour le
vendeur de phyos, il marche très très
bien hein. On est le premier ou second
consommateur en Europe de produits
phytosanitaires suivant les années hein.
Quoi qu'il en soit, on est toujours sur
le podium. Et pour tous ceux qui vendent
effectivement les antibiotos, les
médicaments pour les les animaux, ça va
très bien. Et pour l'industrie
agroalimentaire, ça va très bien parce
que ça leur permet de sous-payer nos
agriculteurs. Donc si le système il a
beau être abject en fait, il fonctionne
pour les puissants. Donc si tu veux au
fond et ben qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On
fait semblant. C'estd que à chaque fois
on a fait les états généraux de
l'alimentation. Alors ça, écoutez les
États généraux, on en a fait un des
trucs qui qui avaient vraiment l'air de
rien. Mais alors celui-là c'est tu vois,
je pense que c'est vraiment mon mon
truc, tu vois, vraiment ma médaille d'or
du truc qui sert à rien, qui dit
vraiment le bullshit d'or, tu vois ce
que je veux dire de l'année si tu veux.
Et et c'est dingue quoi tu vois. Et on
fait semblant de réunir les gens, on dit
plus jamais ça, tu vois. On va
repousser, on arrête les pesticides. Et
si tu veux, tu vois, au moment du
grenelle de l'environnement, c'était
quoi ? C'était, tu vois, c'était 2008
2009. On avait dit "Ah [__] en en
2018, on divise 50 % de pesticides en
moins. Puis tu vois, ben 2018, ça arrive
et tu dis "Ah 2020 ?" Puis 2020 ça
arrive 2025. Et là, toute la presse
unanime saluait le plan de la FNSA, donc
le syndicat majoritaire qui nous
expliquait que on allait encore
repousser, tu vois. Et c'est et c'est un
truc je juste insupportable. C'est juste
insupportable, tu vois, parce qu'on sait
comment bien faire. On sait comment bien
faire. Et je suis désolé mais nos
enfants méritent qu'on le fasse bien, tu
vois.
On sait qu'on on sait comment bien
faire. Qu'est-ce que tu appelles bien
faire ? C'est-à-dire euh on sait comment
nourrir les gens correctement sans trop
de merde dedans, sans perturbateur
endocrinien, sans et ben voilà, tu as
tout dit.
Et et et donc on sait comment bien
faire. Mais la transition entre le repos
des sols qu'on a dopé pendant des
décennies aux produits phytosanitaires
et le productivisme qu'on demande aux
gens. Est-ce que tu penses pas que cette
phase de transition va engendrer des
troubles ou des augmentations de prix
qui seront ingérables pour le pouvoir
politique ?
Écoute, le vrai problème qu'on a
aujourd'hui, c'estd que politiquement
Tu as compris ma question ?
Oui, j'ai très bien compris ta question
parce qu'en fait tu sais sous mes airs
ça tu
tu sais ce que tu sais ce que disait
Ginsbourg ?
Non. Qu'est-ce qu'il me disait ?
Je prends les femmes pour ce qu'elles
sont. Non, je et je Non, on verra ça
plus tard.
D'accord. On verra ça plus tard. Ça
c'est comme tout le reste, ça restera
OK. Et donc bon bref euh ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui la nourriture
si l'argent de la Pâque pour revenir à
l'argent de la Pâque aujourd'hui il sert
à sursubventionner une agriculture dont
on paye les dommages collatéraux. Si
demain, si tu veux on fait payer, on est
pollue payeur. Si demain tu payes, ce
que vaut la dépollution de la flotte, ce
que vaut le le le nombre de morts par ba
par euh bactéries multirésistantes,
l'antibiorésistance et cetera et cetera,
tu verras que notre nourriture
aujourd'hui actuellement, elle est hyper
chère. Donc c'est un choix politique.
C'est que c'est un choix politique de
faire croire qu'elle l'est pas. Elle est
très chère notre nourriture actuellement
hein parce que tu la payes euh tu la
payes avec ta pâque, tu la payes quand
tu l'achètes, tu la payes avec la
dépollution de l'eau, tu la payes avec
ta lutte contre l'antibiot. Exactement.
Mais donc si tu veux, je veux dire cet
argent-là, pourquoi on le met pas dans
un cercle vertueux plutôt que de
continuer à mettre des cotères sur une
jambe de bois ? Tu vois, moi c'est ça
qui me pose problème. C'estàd que à
chaque fois on dit ça va renchérir le
prix de la nourriture mais de toute
façon là il coûte une fortune. Si tu
coûtes si tu comptes tous les dommages
collatéraux que nous payons déjà.
Les politiques par exemple les écolos,
ils en pensent quoi ? Ils se grattent
les oreilles,
ils brassent beaucoup de vent, ils
sculptent beaucoup d'air chaud, ils
prennent des grands tons, des pauvres
mesures et puis des dès qu'il y a le
vent qui souffle un peu trop fort, on
les voit plus. Écoute, moi je trouve que
par exemple, si tu prends le cas de José
Bovet, moi je trouve que il a eu le
courage après avoir mené ses combats
paysans d'aller et de devenir député
européen et de se battre. Et en fait, il
a quand même aussi pris des coups en lui
disant "Mais tu vas dans la machine
bruxelloise, machin et cetera." Sauf
qu'il s'est battu, il s'est battu
concrètement. Et si on n pas des mecs
comme lui qui vont et qui disent "Les
accords de libre échange c'est pas
possible, les OGM c'est pas possible, il
y a rien qui se passe si tu veux." Parce
que moi, je veux bien le truc de se
refermer dans les frontières
aujourd'hui, mais ça tient pas. Si
aujourd'hui, si tu veux, les grandes
batailles qui a à mener pour notre
avenir, ça se fait là-bas. Donc soit tu
les mènes soit tu te caches derrière ton
petit doigt si tu veux. Moi, j'ai pas
l'habitude de me cacher derrière mon
petit doigt. Donc je pense que c'est
bien. Maintenant, je pense que si tu
veux, il y a beaucoup de choses aussi
que nous on peut faire. C'est-à-dire, je
pense qu'il faut se battre, il faut
qu'ils aillent se battre euh que les
députés européens se battent, qui se b
qui se battent à Bruxelles, tout ça, ça
me paraît très bien. Mais je pense que
nous, il y a beaucoup de choses qu'on
peut faire concrètement. C'est-à-dire
que si tu veux à notre mesure, à notre
échelle, si tu achètes en circuit court,
si tu changes un peu ton ton modèle
aussi d'alimentation, tu tu changes
l'économie qu'il y a autour. Tu vois ce
que je veux dire ? Tout ça c'est en
train de bouger aussi aujourd'hui. Moi
je trouve qu'on tu vois je suis pas
déprimée là-dessus. Je pense que je
pense que le le modèle qui essaie de
nous vendre aujourd'hui, l'industrie
aggralimentaire,
le syndicat majoritaire et cetera, il
est mort. Il est mort. Écoute, tu as la
moitié des paysans qui gagnent pas 350 €
par mois. C'est avant on nous disait,
moi quand j'ai sorti mon livre noir de
l'agriculture, on me disait "Ouais mais
il fonctionne ce ce modèle
productivisme, ça marche, les
agriculteurs vivent bien machin." Alors
aujourd'hui, ils vivent pas bien hein,
ils meurent des cancers, des pesticides
qui épendent. Donc je pense qu'on peut
se dire qu'on est au bout du bout. Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? Et se dire
que c'est peut-être un peu le moment de
changer de modèle. Donc euh je veux dire
il y a plus qu'à. Allons-y.
Question d'internet. Qui décide de la
politique agricole ? La France ou
Bruxelles ?
Alors si tu veux, ce qui est bien avec
les politiques françaises, c'est que
généralement quand ils font vraiment une
saloperie, ils disent tout ça c'est de
la faute de Bruxelles. qui se passe si
tu veux par exemple pour vous dire la
dernière réforme de la Pâque c'était on
avait un très bon commissaire qui
s'appelait Datian Fiolos et si il a pas
pu mettre en place la réforme de la PA
qu'il voulait mettre qui était beaucoup
mieux qui était beaucoup plus vertueuse
beaucoup plus tourné vers l'agroécologie
c'est parce que le syndicat majoritaire
français la FNSEA qui est représenté au
niveau européen par la Copa Kogek a fait
du lobbying pour que ce soit de la merde
qui en sorte tu vois ce que je veux dire
donc moi je veux bien qu'on dise c'est
le dictat de Bruxelles mais si tu veut,
ça n'est jamais que ce qu'on en fait.
Bruxelles, tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Si on avait un peu de courage politique,
si on avait si du côté des lobbyiste, il
y avait pas que les [__] pour parler
vulgairement et qu'il y avait un petit
peu les gentils aussi, et ben ça se
passerait mieux si tu veux.
C'est qui les gentils ? Ben si tu veux,
moi j'aimerais bien que que sur les
questions de la politique agricole
commune, on entend plus la confédération
paysane, tu vois, par exemple, hein. Et
c'est vrai que pour le moment, elle est
écrasée par euh par euh le syndicat
majoritaire et qui euh comme il tient en
France euh toutes les chambres
d'agriculture, toutes les saires,
c'est-à-dire les les organisations, les
les sociétés d'aménagement du du
territoire, comme il tient les crédits
agricoles et cetera, fait le même au
niveau de Bruxelles. Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? C'est vrai que si tu veux,
on a un peu de temps en temps une
impression d'être dans un truc bah qui
est lourd quoi, qui est lourd à faire
évoluer parce que si tu veux le système
qu'il est fait manger les gens qui
mangent pas si mal, tu vois. Alors,
c'est sûr que c'est pas les agriculteurs
et c'est pas le consommateur qui s'en
sort, mais effectivement les autres, ben
ils s'en sortent bien. L'industrie
agroalimentaire s'en sort bien,
l'industrie des phyos s'en sort bien. Et
donc, tant que ces gens-là effectivement
auront euh regarde comment tu fais pour
euh pour faire euh valider euh des
nouveaux pesticides, c'est l'industrie
phyopharmaceutique
qui qui donne les études. Tu vois ce que
je veux dire ?
Tu as été voir la MSA ?
Oui.
MSA, ça veut dire
mutuel, social, agricole. Si tu veux, le
truc c'est que c'est le problème de
toutes ces organismes professionnels,
c'est que aujourd'hui ils sont vraiment
dans les mains du syndicat majoritaire.
Tu vois, c'est ça le
les preuves de ça
ou
c'est juste des affabulations ? C'est
juste des affabulations.
Non mais bien sûr, j'ai des preuves de
ça. C'està dire, j'ai j'ai l'épreuve de
si tu veux, j'ai moi j'ai des gens qui
viennent me voir qui me disent voilà
tout ça je te le dis mais je veux pas
que tu tu veux pas je veux pas jamais
apparaître, je veux pas machin, je veux
pas truc tu vois par exemple sur il y a
c'est ça moi d'ailleurs en plus ça me
touche parce que tu vois il y avait un
éleveur qui m'a parlé qui travaillait
pour un le grand groupe
de de viande he il y en a pas 36 c'est
Biga qui publie pas ses comptes
d'ailleurs comme l'actalis parce que ces
gens-là sont intouchables et Euh
bim !
Mais c'est vrai ! Tu veux que je te dise
? C'est vrai, on a il y a la loi pour
les petits qui n'est pas celle que vous
soyez hein.
Tu votes quoi ?
J'ai beaucoup de mal à voter.
Continue, on verra ça après.
Alors et donc ce mec-là, tu vois, parce
qu'il m'avait parlé et que ça s'était su
et ben euh
d'abord on a commencé à plus lui prendre
ses ses bêtes, c'est-à-dire qu'on venait
pas les chercher pour les pour les pour
les mettre à l'abattoir. Donc les bêtes
continuent à grossir, continu à grossir.
Une fois qu'elles étaient trop grosses,
on lui disait qu'elles étaient hors
norme. Ou après, on lui rendait un veau
qui venait de faire tu en mettant deux
têtes et c'est tout. Il restait que ça
du veau. Donc si tu veux te dire que
c'est facile dans ces milieuxlà, c'est
compliqué. Après tu as aussi tous les
mecs qui travaille à la répression des
fraudes en com on appelle maintenant la
protection de la population qui sont il
y a des gens remarquables là-dedans qui
t'expliquent qu'ils ont des pressions de
leur hiérarchie parce que tel groupement
laitier pèse tant d'emploi et que ce
serait bien qu'on ferme sa gueule sur
telle ou telle malversation. Est-ce que
ces Est-ce que ces gens-là, ils ont
pensé à faire appel, par exemple au
hackur pour faire fuiter euh des choses
euh ou des choses comme ça ?
Non, mais c'est peut-être une bonne
idée. Tu as raison. Mais moi non plus,
j'y avais pas pensé. J'avoue.
Le suicide des agriculteurs, ça le parle
? Tu as les chiffres ?
Écoute, ça c'est vraiment une
catastrophe. Tu vois ce que je veux dire
? C'est ce truc de d'accepter que qu'un
jour sur deux, il y a un agriculteur qui
meurt et qui se suicide. Je veux dire,
c'est c'est comme on accepte qu'il qu'il
soit sous-payé, comme on accepte qu'il
meurent des pesticides, qu'ils épendent.
Je c'est un truc, je trouve que la
l'état de solitude dans lequel on laisse
ces agriculteurs, c'est juste pas
possible si tu veux et que sous couvert
que une fois par an, il y a la grand
messe du salon de l'agriculture où on
fasse semblant que tout aille bien,
madame la marquise, si tu veux, je
trouve que c'est juste c'est juste une
catastrophe. Mais c'est une catastrophe
parce que si tu veux, c'est les gens qui
nous nourrissent, tu vois. Je veux dire
c'est il y a rien de plus important au
fond qu' qu'agriculteur
plus que ça
tu vois ils font vivre le territoire
avec le palais il nous connecte avec la
nature ils nous permettent de cuisiner
des bons petits plats pour nos chéries
ou des choses comme ça
ou voilà d'avoir un orgasme gustatif
entre l'accord mai vin qui s'il y avait
pas un agriculteur un viticulteur
derrière nous les français on ferait
quoi
je suis d'accord
50 % de la drague qui s'envole
alors il faut les remercier
je suis d'accord mais
un bon fromage de chèvre avec un
morceau.
Ouais. Ouais. C'est c'est vrai que c'est
ex
Tu as vu ? Tu le vois ?
Ouais, je le vois. Non mais c'est vrai.
Non mais de
le label bio, qu'est-ce que tu en penses
?
Écoute-moi, je ne fais pas partie des
tétracteurs de la bal bio. C'estàd que
pour moi, si tu veux déjà on on arrête
les pesticides chimique, on a gagné
beaucoup beaucoup hein. Quand tu as plus
de 90 % des points de surveillance de
nos autres surfaces qui sont contaminés
par les pesticides, je pense qu'il y a
un moment les gens qui disent en se
pinçant le nez oh le label bio quand
même c'est compliqué machin. Non hein,
je veux dire déjà tout le monde serait
en bio, on serait bien. que déjà
au-dessus des captages de flotte, on
aurait des cultures en bio plutôt que
d'avoir des captages qui sont pleins de
pesticides et après de filer à des
grands groupes, de nettoyer notre eau et
ça va nous coûter du pognon et ce sera
pas si propre, tu vois. Moi, je pense
qu'il y a quand même des systèmes de
Shadog, ce serait quand même bien, tu
vois, de d'arrêter de faire de d'arrêter
de faire ça, quoi. Donc déjà, je suis
pas mécontente. Après, si c'est pour
faire euh du haricot vert bio qui vient
du Kenya euh avec les populations
locales qui peuvent pas se nourrir euh
pour faire des pour faire des cultures
d'exportation, ça juste c'est une
catastrophe, ça c'est sûr, hein. Donc si
tu veux, pour moi bio ça rime avec local
hein, et ça rime avec production de
saison. Donc si c'est pour faire du
biosoussèt euh qui vient du bout du
monde, ça n'a pas de sens. Donc voilà,
maintenant au moins il y a plus de
pesticides chimique. C'est déjà ça de
gagner, j'ai envie de te dire.
La pêche.
Oh ben écoute, tous les trucs de
surpêche, c'est une catastrophe aussi.
Je veux pas dire le contraire. Je veux
dire, on est dans un monde de fou. Et
comment on reconnaît un beau Omar ?
Ça, j'adore le homar. Qu'est-ce que
c'est ?
Comment tu le choisis sur le marché ? On
reviendra sur la pêche après.
Écoute, moi je j'avoue que le homar, je
ne l'achète que quand je vais dans mon
coin en Bretagne.
Comment tu fais pour le choisir ?
Et je fais confiance à mon pêcheur qui
me l'apporte, qui me dit qu'il a pêché
la veille. Le truc bouge encore et
j'adore. Et
c'est la longueur des antennes.
Mais ouais. Et puis la couleur aussi, il
faut qu'il soit bien bleu. Ouais. Mais
bleu, ça dépend de l'omar que tu prends.
La longueur des antennes, faut pas que
les antennes soient cassées parce que ça
veut dire que les les homars ont été
secoués ou ils sont tabassés entre eux
pendant la
dans le dans la dans le bac après dans
le dans le vifier.
Revenons à la surpêche.
Ouais, vas-y.
Tu penses que les gens ils sont au
courant ou ?
Ah oui, là je pense que les gens ils
peuvent pas ne pas être au courant
aujourd'hui de la surpêche. Pourquoi ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Vous faites des
petit vous faites des petits coucous.
C'est cool. Euh
consommation de viande.
Écoute, moi je suis pas végan, hein.
Donc si tu veux le truc aujourd'hu
Pourquoi tu pousses ce grand soupirement
quand tu
Parce que ça me fatigue, en fait je
parce que je parce que je me fais
insulter assez souvent par les végan
et parce que ça me fatigue parce que si
tu veux aujourd'hui je trouve qu'il y a
une je veux pas me faire de potes mais
ça m'est égal. Il y a une alliance
objective si tu veux entre les végan et
pour moi l'élevage industriel.
C'est-à-dire à force de dire que tout
est dans le même panier, que finalement
du petit élevage de proximité à
l'élevage concentrationnaire, c'est
toujours la même chose. C'est toujours
la battage à la fin, c'est toujours la
bête qui meurt, ce qui est vrai hein, je
veux pas dire le contraire. Et ben tu
fais comme si au fond il y a d'un côté
effectivement les salopards de d'verc
et de l'autre côté les vertueux
végétariens
végan parce que c'est pas la même chose.
Et je suis désolée mais ça me gêne comme
ça me gêne que des copains éleveurs à
moi qui font vraiment tout pour leurs
animaux se retrouvent avec leur étable
peinte en rouge avec marqué assassin. Tu
vois ça, je je comprends pas en fait
parce que malgré tout nos élevages font
nos paysages que sans élevage cétait
avant ça.
Non mais c'est toujours c'est toujours
vrai. C'est toi qui qui aime le
Montsint-Michel
fait.
Tu crois qu'il y aurait pas de brebis
qu'il y aurait pas de mouton ? On serait
bien dans notre entretien des pralésich.
OK. D'accord. Mais les grands
céréaliers, tu crois qu'ils font nos
paysages ?
Quand tu vois du colza un peu partout,
tu dis quoi ? Je suis dit tiens oh il y
a Renault ah il y a Peugeot il se roule
il roule au colza mais je pas dit le
contraire l'agrocarburant il y a rien de
pire moi je suis hyper contre les
agrocarburants d'ailleurs je n'appelle
pas ça des biocarburant
revenons au revenons au végan
et donc et donc non mais ce que je veux
te dire c'est juste que les maqu tu les
entretiens comment le Pays Basque tu
l'entretiens comment si tu as pas des
animaux si tu as pas des élevages
extensifs et ces élevages extensifs ça
n'a rien à voir avec les élevages
concentrationnair bon et pour autant
effectivement les bêtes sont abattus à
la fin et effectivement si tu veux voilà
C'est vrai, il y a c il y a cette il y a
il y a l'abattage.
Comment tu te positionnes par rapport à
l'exploitation des animaux ?
Qu'est-ce que tu veux dire par là ?
Bah qu'est-ce que tu veux dire par là ?
C'est une question d'internet.
Bah c'est bon c'estàd que si c'est
l'exploitation des animaux question
exact parce qu'il vient de finir de me
la taper. L'exploitation des animaux est
moins important que la conservation des
paysages point d'interrogation.
Voilà. Alors voilà donc si tu veux c'est
pas l'exploitation pour moi des animaux
quand tu vas dans tu vois par exemple il
y a un mec que j'adore qui s'appelle
Gérard le Gruel qui est éleveur
d'agneaux de pressalé à créance dans la
Manche. Je crois pas qu'on puisse dire
qu'il y a une exploitation des animaux
si tu veux.
Tu as déjà tué de tes mains ?
Non. Bah non parce que moi je suis une
petite parisienne donc j'ai pas tué de
mes mains si tu veux.
Un petit lapin, une petite pou
une mouche peut-être. Oui mais c'est
tout hein. Pas plus. Une araignée
peut-être aussi c'est mal d'ailleurs
j'aurais pas
Tu as jamais vécu ton enfance à la
campagne ?
Ah non j'ai pas vécu mon enfance. tuer
le cochon. Enlever un œil à un poulet ou
lui couper la tête et laisser courir.
Jamais.
Jamais. Jamais. Toi, tu as fait des
choses comme ça toi ? Ah
bah ouais,
c'est vrai.
Ouais. Pas tuer le cochon mais le lapin,
les poules.
Bah le truc de garin quoi. Plumer une
poule avec de l'eau chaude, avec du gros
sel. Tu as jamais fait ça ?
Non.
Tu as déjà fait les vendanges ?
Ouais.
Quand ? Où ?
Je les ai déjà fait en Bourgogne
chez chez Dominique Dorin qui est à
Saint-Aubin euh à Saint-Émilion.
Tu as pressé ?
Ouais. Chez chez chez Doran. Ouais.
Est-ce que tu as suivi la vinification ?
Ouais. Ben ouais.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire coller ?
Alors ça si tu veux c'est les nouveaux
c'est à base d'œuf hein maintenant. Moi
c'est effectivement
de terre.
Oui, mais si tu veux moi si si la
question c'est est-ce que je suis plutôt
v nature ou pas v nature ? Je suis
plutôt 20 nature. Si moi on fait moins
on fait de comment dire
à quoi servent les sulfites ?
Avoir mal à la tête le lendemain.
Empêcher l'oxydation.
Mais bien sûr, bien sûr. C'est pour
empêcher l'oxydation. Mais
qu'est-ce que c'est le mer captant ?
Je sais pas.
Ça sent l'œuf pourri.
Et et après on va tout faire. On va
faire lesess
machin. Écoute euh
moi je suis euh
je en en ayant travaillé enfin en ayant
suivi beaucoup de mecs qui faisaient de
la vinification nature, j'ai été assez
touchée quand même par cette espèce de
de volonté effectivement de pas utiliser
des levures industrielles, de faire en
sorte de respecter au mieux leur raisin,
la vinification, le processus de
vinification et cetera. Pour autant, si
tu veux, c'est un art la vinification.
Donc euh
on laisse pas faire comme ça, tu vois.
Je veux dire, les grands vignerons, ils
sont euh très précautionneux de leur
vin. Euh et euh je sais pas si euh même
le plus grand vigneron nature, s'il
voyait qu'il y avait besoin euh de temps
en temps de coller comme tu dis, il le
ferait pas. J'en sais rien et je sais
pas qui je suis pour juger ça, tu vois.
Voilà.
Ton vin préféré
et pourquoi ?
Je sais pas quel est mon vin préféré.
J'ai plusieurs vins que j'aime et je les
aime pas au même moment ni de la même
manière, tu vois. Par exemple,
c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup ce que
fait le vignon Dominique de rein qui a
Saint-Aubin. J'aime beaucoup ce qu'il
fait. J'aime beaucoup plusieurs de ses
vins qui sont très différents les uns
des autres. J'aime beaucoup de façon
aussi complètement autre quelqu'un qui
fait des vinifications beaucoup plus
classiques et
ça nous dit pas ce qu'il y a en bouche
là
parce que parce que si tu veux je sais
pas que que te dire tu vois il a il a 50
50 v 20 que j'aime que ce soit son pomar
euh tu vois je veux dire je son son
saintubin premier cru enfin je veux dire
il y a plein de vins que j'aime chez
lui. Quand tu vas par contre, tu vois à
Bordeaux, moi il y a un mec dont j'adore
ce qu'il fait et qui pourtant est
quelqu'un qui est un wine maker
mondialement connu et qui fait partie
des plus grands châteaux Bordelait.
J'adore ce qu'il fait, c'est Stéphan de
Renoncour et je trouve que son domaine
de là en côte de question, c'est quelque
chose de magnifique. Mais ça pour
beaucoup de gens qui aiment la
Tu veux pas nous le décrire
le domaine de là ?
Non. ce qu'il y a en bouche.
Bah ça dépend des années. J'ai envie de
te dire
la dernière chose que tu es goûté.
Le dernier que j'ai goûté
tentendre me parler de vin.
Alors tout le monde s'en fout mais
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien savoir
ton degré d'implication dans le milieu.
Si vraiment tu t'es fait le palais, si
on t'a éduqué les papis.
Comment
parle-moi d'un vin ?
Ben écoute, je sais pas duquel te parler
en fait. Je sais Parle-moi d'un d'un
Murceau par exemple.
Oui, mais alors tu vois c'est pas ça que
j'aurais eu envie dont j'aurais eu envie
de te parler. Donc
Château neuf du pape,
c'est très bon. Mais c'est
unospice de bonne,
ça c'est bon.
Alors parle-moi de l'hospice de bone.
Non, je vais pas te parler de ça. Je
vais te parler du pomard de Dorin.
Euh
ou je vais te parler du code de question
de de Rena Courant. Je sais pas.
Attention, on écoute.
Non mais parce que je suis pas une
spécialiste si tu veux. Moi je suis une
amatrice en fait. Moi je me pique pas
d'être tu vois justement
quand tu dois parler de vin un étranger.
Ah moi je parle pas de vin.
Non mais quand tu dois par exemple tu as
une copine américaine qui vient manger à
la maison, tu lui parles du vin comment
?
Alors en fait moi les gens qui parlent
de vin me font chier dans l'ensemble
hein. Ce que j'aime c'est le boire et
c'est pas disertter su c'est quand même
les gens qui te font une exégèse après
t'avoir sauté sur comment ils t'ont
baisé. Ça me fait un peu pareil en fait.
Est-ce que ça cette ça cette on va
formuler ça différemment. Est-ce que ça
ta mémoire olfactive te permet de de
réfléchir ?
Je sais pas ce que ça veut dire ça. Ce
que je veux dire c'est que tu vois je en
fait moi j'ai un vrai truc avec ça
maintenant c'est que je les connais les
vignerons. C'est-à-dire que par exemple
si tu veux quand j'ai un champagne et je
pense à David l'éclapard, je pense à la
façon dont il va il l'a fait et j'aime
ce qu'il fait quand je suis en fumé.
tu es capable de le reconnaître à
l'aveugle.
Je sais pas si je suis capable de
reconnaître à l'aveugle. Je vais te dire
un truc. Ça c'était comment il s'appelle
? J'adore ce mec qui a rien à voir, qui
est pas du tout en vigification nature
non plus qui s'appelle celui qui fait
Valandro Tunevin
Tun Vin il m'expliquait que donc il fait
son grand cru Valandropre de un grand
cru classé B de Saint-Émilion et il me
dit tu vois on dit toujours et donc
c'est un mec qui a un palais incroyable
très très il fait un très très bon vin
tuaimes ou tuaimes pas c'est un très bon
vin et il me dit on dit toujour les
grands dégustateurs te disent toujours
bien sûr à l'aveugle je reconnais c je
reconnais ça il me dit écoute-moi, c'est
pas compliqué, à l'aveugle, j'ai pas
reconnu mon vent. Donc si tu veux, ça me
fait marrer ça. Et je vais dire, je les
ai vu les grands, les très grands
dégustateurs au moment des primaires à
Bordeaux, si tu veux. Des primeurs. Les
primaires ça c'est c'est Parti
socialiste.
La droite des primeurs. Ouais.
Et c'est que effectivement euh
ils se plantent, ils se plantent eux
aussi. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Il
dégo il dégustent, ils se plantent à
l'aveugle. Donc si tu veux, moi je veux
bien à l'aveugle. Non, je suis bonne à
rien. Mais je pense pas qu'il soit bon à
grand-chose non plus. Tu vois, si si il
notent aussi bien les grands les grands
châteaux, c'est qu'ils vont les déguster
sur place. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Donc il y a un moment, il faut quand
même dire les choses comme elles sont.
Ouais. Bon, allez, changeons de sujet.
Vente de terre aux puissances
étrangères, tu as un point de vue
là-dessus ?
Vente de terre aux puissances étrangères
? Bah je trouve que là alors là tu vois
pour le coup
quand j'ai fait mon vino business sur le
bordelait et que j'ai dit c'est quand
même pas possible tous ces châteaux qui
passe sous pavillon chinois et cetera et
cetera, tout le monde me dit oh là là
toutou bijou ça n'arrivera jamais sur
quelle année ça
sur 2013
ça n'arrivera jamais sur les terres
nourricières jamais les terres vivrières
jamais bon ben maintenant on y est donc
si tu veux moi je trouve ça génial parce
qu'ils ont essayé de faire des tu vois
des amendements ils ont foutu un député
dessus soit-disant on avait trouvé la
parade C'est extraordinaire. Pouf, il y
a eu encore des milliers d'hectares qui
sont partis. Donc euh je sais pas ce
qu'on attend si tu veux. Je sais pas ce
qu'on attend là. Je comprends pas bien
en fait. Je comprends pas bien.
Comment te nourris-tu ?
Le mieux que je peux.
Comment ?
Bah écoute, ça pour le coup, moi pour
moi la je vais pas te mentir, pour moi
la bouffe c'est un budget hein.
C'est-à-dire que
bien
je sais pas parce que je suis pas très
bonne pour faire mes comptes. Je suis
quelqu'un d'assez j'avoue c'est pas bien
mais assez dépensié. Et donc je fais pas
vraiment mes comptes. Je j'essaie juste
de faire en sorte que mon découvert
reste pas habissal, c'est tout. Mais euh
Et dans quelle banque ?
On les salue. On s'en fout. Non
non
si on s'en fout.
Tu es plutôt à la BNP ou à la Poste ?
Je suis ni l'un ni l'autre. Il en reste
d'autres.
Crédit crédit collaboratif
non plus.
D'accord.
Et euh
donc le budget par mois pour te nourrir
et comment tu fais ? Ben écoute, j'aime
moi j'aime bien faire mon marché. J'aime
bien euh
y aller avec mes filles. J'aime bien
choisir chez mon primeur les produits de
saison. J'aime bien faire vivre le
poissonnier du coin. J'aime bien euh
voilà, c'est ça en fait pour moi. Les
courses c'est une histoire. C'est un un
repas qu'on fait en qu'on va faire
ensemble avec mes filles. Et voilà,
c'est tout ça.
Alors question d'internet. Ouais,
il me faudrait deux trois mesures phares
à mettre en place pour changer
profondément l'agriculture.
Bah écoute, deux trois mesures phares,
c'est pas compliqué hein. Demain, on
fait en sorte que si tu veux au lieu de
filer des aides comme on le fait
aujourd'hui au à l'hectare, on file des
aides. On l'a fait un petit peu, c'est
un peu mieux déjà. Plus effectivement
aux petites structures qui utilisent de
la main d'œuvre, on va tout changer, tu
vas voir parce que là aujourd'hui les
aides, elles fonctionnent comment ?
historique. C'est-à-dire qu'au fond ceux
qui étaient riches et qui touchaient des
grosses aides jusque- là continu à en
toucher à l'hectare, on a essayé de
faire de prendre un peu en en compte
aussi le nombre de travailleurs mais on
le fait pas assez. Donc plus tu es gros,
plus tu touches. Plus tu es vieux, plus
tu touches. Plus tu es gros, plus tu
touches et finalement on s'en fout un
peu de ce que tu fais sur place. Bon, il
y a quand même des leviers où on peut
changer les choses, tu vois. On peut
faire en sorte Je crois qu'il faut le
couper mon portable. Tu es d'accord ?
Ouais. Oui. Raccroche, raccroche.
Et donc c'est Et donc
t'inquiète. Et donc du coup, si tu veux
euh
moi je pense que déjà rien que ça si tu
veux on changerait on va couper parce
que moi ça me voilà tu me le mets sur tu
me le mets sur silencieux ou sur voilà
parce que voilà parce que là c'est vrai
que du coup voilà ça me perturbe.
Donc les mesures phares
bon la mesure phare déjà c'est de faire
en sorte effectivement que tu mettes
plus d'aide sur les plus petites
structures qui font bien. C'est pas très
compliqué ça hein. Tu vois je te dis tu
arrêtes tu tu arrêtes de filer des aides
historiques. tu arrêtes de filer des
aides à l'hectare et ça va très très
bien se passer mieux. Après moi je pense
que tu mets en place pollueur payeur
c'est au fond tu pollues tu paye. Là
aujourd'hui la dépollution c'est nous
qui la payons. Tu vas voir que si c'est
pol payeur ça va bien se passer. Pareil
pour l'irrigation. L'irrigation il paye
pas le prix de l'eau. Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? Qui est-ce qui paye la prix
de l'eau ? Qui est-ce qui finance les
grandes bassines gigantesques ? C'est
nous. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Donc
moi je pense que c'est pas très
compliqué et juste il faut un peu de
volonté politique.
Bon, tu as écrit un dernier bouquin
qui s'appelle C'est vous le prince
charmant ?
Le prince charmant c'est
le prince charmant c'est vous.
Ouais.
Ça parle de quoi ?
De moi.
Ça fait un peu désespéré housewife quand
même.
C'est un peu ça, on va pas se mentir.
Sauf que je suis pas housewiife mais
c'est un peu ça. C'est un peu le blues
des cadras. C'est mon blouse de la milf.
Je t'emmerde.
Ouais, mais c'est vrai que c'est un peu
ça. C'est vrai que c'est un peu ça si tu
veux. Au fond, c'est
comment on est aujourd'hui avec cette
révolution sexuelle qui nous a tout
apporté. On est extraordinaire, on a le
droit de travailler, on a le droit de
faire tout ce qu'on veut. C'est
extraordinaire, c'est extraordinaire.
Sauf que les trois/4 des emmerdes sont
toujours pour nous si tu veux. Tu vois
le truc de la charge mentale, du fait
que il faut penser à tout pour les
enfants, c'est quand même pour nous. que
nos mecs sont effectivement devenus très
très gentils mais que maintenant ils se
posent des questions de savoir ce qu'ils
vont devenir pas devenir et du coup mol
un peu couille molle et que du coup si
tu veux euh on se retrouve avec des mecs
qui travaillent plus tu vois par exemple
et donc si tu veux c'est bien gentil
mais euh tu as l'impression que si la
libération de la femme c'est juste que
j'ai le droit de bosser pour 15 d'avoir
toute la charge mentale sur la tête tout
le poids de la maison et de courir dans
tous les sens pour faire bouillir la
marmite ça devient compliqué si tu veux
et donc ce roman au fond c'est un peu ma
vie si tu veux c'est-à-dire dire comment
tu fais pour être sur le terrain pour
être disant c'est journaliste
conquérante wou super et d'un autre côté
toute la trivialité du quotidien où tu
te dis qu'au fond
bah quelque part tu aimerais bien qu'il
y a un prince charmant qui arrive qui te
sauve et que tu es pas tout sur la
tronche en permanence tu vois voilà et
donc c'est un peu ça c'est moi qui court
entre mes enfants
euh le personnage qui est mon ex-mi et
effectivement qui essaie de de croire
que le prince charmement est possible et
que tout va s'arranger à la fin. Et
voilà. Donc c'est un peu mais c'est
assez générationnel parce que c'est
toutes les nanas de mon âge qui courent
dans tous les sens et qui ont beaucoup
de choses sur le coin de la figure et
c'est pas si facile en fait. On n'est
pas Wonder Woman.
C'est c'est parce que tu as été élevé
dans le dans le phénomène de princesse
chos que tu étais élevé là-dedans. Tu
dans le vrai problème ça c'est le vrai
cauchemar un
cauchemar pour les mecs.
Non c'est un cauchemar pour nous.
C'est-à-dire que si tu veux, on nous a
fait croire qu'il y a un mec
Pourquoi tu croises tes bras ?
Parce que parce que parce que parce que
c'est vrai que c'est c'est tu vois ce ce
bouquin, j'avais vraiment envie de le
faire. Je me suis vraiment battue pour
le faire et mais en même temps, c'est
vrai que je me suis jamais mise autant à
poil que pour ce livre. C'estd qu'au
fond, j'ai jamais dévoilé ma vie privée
que là je le fais au fond parce que même
si c'est fantasmé, c'estécrit comme une
comédie parce que je voulais que ce soit
drôle, tu vois. Et donc c'est ça, on se
marre. Je voulais que ce soit comme un
sketch de Forestie, je me suis jamais
autant dévoilée que ça. Donc c'est vrai
que tu vois, je suis comme ça parce que
je suis un peu sur la défensive de fait
et euh
et je pense qu'effectivement le prince
charmant c'est surtout un cauchemar pour
nous parce que
pourquoi ?
Mais parce que c'est un cauchemar pour
nous. Parce qu'on l'attend ce [__] de
prince charmand qui vient jamais parce
que vous êtes comme vous êtes et bon
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on vous
aime. Mais si tu veux on l'attend, on
espère ce mec extraordinaire qui va
arriver, qui va nous sauver de tout, tu
vois. Et c'est vrai que si tu veux,
c'est ce que je raconte, c'est qu'au
fond finalement je m'en sors quand je
comprends ce que m'a dit mon psy depuis
15 ans qui n'existe pas,
que le prince charmment c'est vous,
c'est toi, c'est moi. Enfin, tu vois, je
veux dire chacun et son propre prince
charmant mais il y aura pas une personne
qui va m'enlever sur son cheval blanc,
pourtant ce serait bien chouette, hein.
Et me sauver à moi-même. Tu vois ce que
je veux dire ? Et donc voilà. Mais sauf
que c'est vrai que c'est compliqué et
c'est vrai que quand en plus tu fais un
métier comme le mien ou tu es toujours
par mon et par vos et cetera,
c'est quoi le stéréotype du prince
charmant ?
Tel que je l'imaginais que je le rêvais.
Ah ben écoute, c'est extraordinaire, il
s'occupe de tout, il gagne très bien sa
vie. Il est hyper gentil, hyper
attentionné, il pense à tout,
il change les spots quand ça pète.
Enfin, tout se passe bien, tu vois, j'ai
envie de te dire.
Et en fait en vrai, dans la vraie vie,
ben tu te retrouves pour tes 40 ans avec
ton mec qui a pas pensé à t'acheter un
gâteau d'anniversaire et que tu as une
grosse éponge avec des bougies
princesses que tu as mis dedans et tu
dis un grand moment de solitude. Tu vois
ce que je veux dire ? En fait, c'est ça.
Et donc au fond ce que je raconte c'est
qu'entre on éponge en bougie princesse
et et autres spot non changé si tu veux
que bah la vie quotidienne est pas
évidente et que on a beau être
soi-disant Wonder Woman qui court
partout pour défendre tu vois le petit
paysan qui pour qui c'est dur et ben
voilà c'est pas fa c'est pas facile tu
vois qui a effectivement cette cette
charge mentale qui a effectivement ce
truc de ces hommes nouveaux qui
aujourd'hui s'occupent un peu des
enfants mais sous prétexte il s'en
occupe un peu ben bah du coup ils ont le
droit et c'est très bien peut-être mais
de plus bosser, de réfléchir à ce qu'ils
vont faire et du coup toi tu es là euh
ben tu as un peu tout sur les épaules
quand même en fait et bon bah j'irai pas
jusqu'à dire que c'est pas facile mais
bon il y a des moments
des moments c'est pas si facile quand
même.
[Rires]
Voilà. Et donc voilà.
Et c'est quoi le prince charmant
maintenant en toi ?
Ben si tu veux déjà maintenant j'ai
compris que euh
bah que le prince charmant voilà que le
princecharm c'est moi. C'est-à-dire que
effectivement que il y a pas euh que
personne ne me sauvera si tu veux et que
donc si tu veux il y a un moment euh bah
les choses sont comme elles sont mais il
y aura pas une personnalité
extraordinaire qui va m'enlever sur son
cheval. Je trouve ça triste hein, note
bien parce que j'ai mis bien l'idée qui
est cette personne extraordinaire qui
existe.
Genre grand, balaise avec un grand
cheval euh un peu genre un peu genre
rustre bûcheron.
Alors ça c'est un vrai truc, c'est
marrant que tu dises ça parce que de
fait et ça je veux pas me faire copine
avec les féminismes enfin tant pis.
C'est que je pense qu'à force d'avoir le
mec tellement gentil tu vois et qui
s'occupe des tu vois
un peu androgine non ? Ouais. Et ben de
fait, c'est vrai qu'on a un petit
fantasme du mec un peu macho. Pas trop
hein, parce que il pas à question.
Pas trop. Bah un mec respectueux, tu
vois, malgré tout, tu vois, mais un peu
macho où finalement quelque part on est
une épaule de bûcheron sur laquelle
poser sa tête de temps en temps, tu
vois, ou ce soit pas juste
ce truc effectivement dans lequel on est
aujourd'hui et où ces mecs sont
charmants. Mais
mais c'est vrai qu'ils sont, tu vois,
j'avais l'impression, moi je j'avais
l'impression d'être devenu le mari en
fait. Et en fait, ça c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué aussi. C'est compliqué
aussi. Est-ce qu'on a Est-ce qu'on
rêvait d'être le mari un jour ? Non. Tu
vois, on a jamais rêvé d'être le mari.
On est devenu aujourd'hui le mari plus
la femme. Parce que quand même, malgré
tout, les trois/4 des emmerdes, tu vois,
penser à l'inscription à la piscine,
l'inscription à la colo, faire les
courses, les emmener chez le chez le
médecin, c'est quand même toujours nous.
Plus en fait après, bon ben comme après
ces nouveaux hommes et ben ils ont envie
de se chercher, de se trouver
professionnellement. Bon, il faut quand
même malgré tout assurer assurer euh
financièrement et que on a la gueule à
la maison parce que on existe trop. Donc
c'est pas évident. Tu vois
comment tu te positionnes sur les
questions de féminisme au 21e siècle ?
Mais c'est pas facile. Je pense que
c'est mais je pense que c'est pas facile
pour les mecs non plus hein. Mais euh
je sais pas comment je me positionne. Si
tu veux je quand j'entends des
féministes, moi je trouve que si tu si
tu veux me parler de mitou par exemple.
C'est quoi mitou ? Tu sais, balance ton
port blabli blabou.
Ah ouais, balance ton port. Ouais.
Bon, si je veux te dire que il y a pas
des ports sur cette terre, il y en a
hein. Que moi même en tant que
journaliste, j'ai jamais eu des gros
cons qui ont essayé de de de se servir
de leur position hiérarchique pour
obtenir des faveurs. C'est évident.
Maintenant, ce truc de
ça t déjà arrivé
bien sûr
de faire à
jamais. Non, jamais. Alors ça vraiment,
c'est un truc, je l'ai payé parce que de
fait perdu des jobs et c'est
inacceptable. Tu es sorti du bois un peu
pour les balancer ?
Non, parce que ça ne me plaît pas. Ça me
pla
Je m'en fous. Je m'en fous si tu veux.
Je veux dire de fait si tu veux ce que
je pense c'est que à l'avenir, il faut
éduquer les gamins, les petits garçons
pour que ils pensent pas que une fille
quand elle dit non, c'est peut-être. Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? Ça, je suis
entièrement d'accord. Maintenant euh si
tu veux ce mouvement euh de délation
généralisée où au fond on a le droit de
balancer sur les réseaux sociaux ou euh
dans les médias le nom de tel et tel mec
sans aucune vérification me gêne
vraiment vraiment ça me gêne si tu veux
parce que on va se rendre compte qu'il y
a des mecs qui ont été balancés qui
méritaient pas de naître et que par
contre il y a des gros ports qui doivent
être encore bien tranquilles parce
qu'ils ont suffisamment les manettes du
pouvoir en main pour qu'on leur foute
bien la paix. Tu vois ce que je
en tête là ? Non. Oui. Donc si tu veux,
il y a un moment, moi je veux bien, tu
vois, mais si c'est juste pour qu'on
fasse semblant, qu'on sorte quatre noms
et que ce soit business as usual, tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? Ce soit
toujours la même merde, j'ai envie de te
dire ça me plaît pas. Je préférerais
qu'on Tu vois, ça c'est comme pour
l'agriculture hein. Le tout c'est pas de
mettre en exergue deux trucs qui
marchent bien et continuer le même
bordel avec les mêmes usages de produits
phytosanitaires. Là c'est pas de dire il
y a trois gros ports, on les a identifié
maintenant tout va très bien madame la
marquise. C'est pas vrai. Donc il faut
un truc de fond, il faut éduquer les
momes, ça c'est sûr. Mais par contre euh
il faut aussi que chacun ait sa place.
Et je pense qu'aujourd'hui dans les
relations hommes-femme c'est compliqué.
Je pense que c'est compliqué.
Tu as des recommandations pour faire
changer tout ça ?
Non j'en ai pas. Tu vois, moi j'ai déjà
du mal. J'ai j'étais obligé d'écrire un
roman pour raconter ça de façon marrante
sur comment je m'en sors toute seule
dans mon propre bordel. Donc je me
permettrai pas de juger sur le sur ce
que doivent faire les autres. Tu vois ce
que je veux dire ? J'ai juste essayé moi
de m'en sortir à ma juste mesure et de
me rendre compte que de temps en temps
en tant que femme, j'avais le droit un
de pas avoir tout sur le dos et de dire
merde quand j'avais envie de dire merde,
de me barrer quand j'avais envie de me
barrer et effectivement d'avoir un mec
attentionné si j'en avais envie ou un
bûcheron si j'en avais envie. Donc rien
que ça déjà ça a été un énorme progrès.
Tu peux même pas t'imaginer.
Si si, j'imagine tout à fait. Question
d'Internet. Qu'est-ce qui cause cette
situation ? L'éducation, la culture,
je pense qu'il y a un peu de tout ça. Je
pense que je pense que
je pense que si tu veux pour les mecs
les mecs qui se cherchent et qui sont
devenus très féminins, je pense qu'il y
a effectivement
qui assument leur part de féminité.
Ou qui assum leur part de féminité. Et
c'est très bien. Moi, je trouve très
bien que les gens les mecs maintenant
s'occupent de leurs enfants et cetera et
cetera. Je trouve ça très bien. Mais je
pense qu'on est arrivé aujourd'hui à un
truc où au fond,
je vais dire un truc très très vulgaire.
J'ai le droit.
Bien sûr, tu as le droit. Je crois qu'on
leur a un peu trop coupé les couilles
aux mecs. C'est-à-dire que je pense
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui euh on se
retrouve finalement avec des mecs qui
s'occupe très bien de leurs enfants, qui
sont très gentils, qui machin qui trouve
et à qui on a donné une place presque
féminine si tu veux et que du coup c'est
compliqué pour eux mais c'est aussi
hyper compliqué pour nous. Et je pense
que ça c'est un contre-coup
effectivement de mes 68 si tu veux.
C'est très bien libération de la femme
c'est extraordinaire. Voilà on est
devenu des femmes successful on
travaille machin et cetera. Pour nous
c'est génial et d'un autre côté c'est
aussi l'enfer parce que comme je te dis,
on a le droit de tous. OK, on travaille,
on travaille comme des folles, on gagne
notre vie. On a quand même toujours sur
le dos toutes les questions. Mais je te
dis mais toutes les questions de de je
veux dire voilà de si j'achète les
chaussettes de mes enfants, c'est que je
sais pas toi si tu as des enfants mais
qui s'occupe d'acheter les chaussettes,
les culottes, le machin, les courses, le
truc, c'est toujours nous. Tu vois, qui
s'occupe de savoir si les vaccins sont à
jour, le machin, le truc, c'est toujours
nous. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Mais
le mec effectivement il est à côté et
d'un autre côté il a une nana qui
réussit, qui prend une place de plus en
plus importante. Il essaie de s'occuper
des des mots mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas entre guillemets encore valorisé
suffisamment. C'est-à-dire qu'au fond,
on le regarde comme l'homme au foyer.
Est-ce que c'est si bien vu ? Et tu vois
moi finalement qu'est-ce que je raconte
? C'est que j'avais un homme au foyer et
que je n'en pouvais plus parce que je me
retrouvais je ne trouvais plus ma place
de mère. J'ai l'impression d'être le
père et j'avais pas envie d'être le
père. hein, et que j'avais envie qu'il
aille bosser et que j'avais envie
presque d'un bûcheron, tu vois. Tu vois
ce que je veux dire ? Et c'est affreux
de dire ça. Je sens que je vais pas me
faire copiner avec les féministes, mais
si tu veux voilà, c'est vrai. Tu vois,
il y a un moment tu dis "Mais c'est mais
j'ai pas signé pour ça, mais comment ça
se fait ? Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Mais je comprends que tu te cherches,
mais trouve-toi vite." Tu vois,
tu trouves que je suis monstrueuse ?
Non du tout. On n'est pas là pour juger.
Ça tombe bien, j'ai envie de te dire.
Quel prochain sujet ne nous cherche pas
quand même ? Quel prochain sujet tu
aimerais aborder en tant que journaliste
?
Je sais pas. Tu sais en fait maintenant
ce que j'ai, j'ai un truc de luxe total
pour moi, c'est depuis que je suis
devenue éditrice. C'est qu'en fait
maintenant je mets les gens sur les
sujets que j'aimerais voir traiter, tu
vois, et ça me plaît bien. Donc euh
donc il y a un mec qui s'appelle
Jean-Marie Godard que que entre
guillemets que j'ai mis en immersion
chez les flics qui m'a fait un parole de
flic hyper bien sur le quotidien des
flics, sur leur burnout, sur leur machin
et cetera. J'ai essayé de son 06, tu
nous l'enverras d'ailleurs.
Avec plaisir. Et si tu veux euh pour moi
euh
c'est même plus je me pose pas la
question de ce que je veux faire moi. Je
me pose la question des meilleures
personnes pour faire les sujets qui
m'intéressent au moment où ça
m'intéresse et dont je pense qu'ils
peuvent faire bouger la société.
Quels sont les sujets là que qui te font
kiffer
là ? Tu vois pare
la condition des flics.
La condition des flics. Je trouvais ça
intéressant parce que si tu veux quand
tu comprends que les mecs viennent avec
leur rouleau de PQ dans leur
commissariat qui s'achètent eux même
leur matos et et qui sont toujours au
bord du burnout, bah tu comprends que
entre guillemets le service public qui
fait qu'on fait encore société et qui en
fait le rempart pour qu'on dorme bien,
il est dans un état de décrépitude
totale, tu vois. Et quand Jean-Marie
Godard réussit à être à aller au
courbas, c'est-à-dire l'endroit l'HP,
l'hôpital psychiatrique où ils vont
faire leur burnout et que tu vois les
récits de ces flics en plein burnout qui
ne veulent plus retourner sur le terrain
tellement ils ont peur et qui en plus
ont peur du regard des autres sur eux
parce que euh parce que tu vois euh
finalement accepter d'être soigné, c'est
accepter d'être c'est de dire que tu es
faible. Euh je me dis on n'est pas bien.
Euh quand j'ai Benoît Habito qui me fait
son paysan résistant pour me montrer
comment en 3 4 ans tu peux changer d'un
système d'une exploitation productiviste
en un modèle vertueux. Ça ça me fait
kiffer quand j'ai euh par exemple Thomas
Porcher euh qui me fait son traité
hérétique pour pas dire son antimanuel
d'économie pour me dire au fond on passe
temps à nous dire que on n jamais
réformé le le marché du travail. Je peux
vous dire que depuis 7 8 ans, on a eu
déjà 165 réformes. Je trouve que ça fait
du bien. Et donc si tu veux, moi pour
moi, mon combat demain, c'est ça. C'est
pas tellement ce que je vais faire moi.
C'est ce que vont faire les meilleurs
d'entre nous pour faire bouger la
société.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable que tu
vas laisser sur les réseaux ?
Moi ce que je veux, c'est qu'il continue
à rêver. Moi ce que je veux, c'est qu'on
arrête de pourrir la tête de notre
jeunesse à lui faire croire qu'il a que
plus rien n'est possible, que tout est
figé. C'est faux. Je veux dire, le monde
leur appartient et il faut continuer à
rêver. Il faut que personne ne pourrisse
leurs rêves parce que ils ont les moyens
de changer le monde et on va on va
changer ce monde, tu vois, avec eux.
Voilà. Et j'aimerais qu'on arrête de
mettre cette jeunesse de côté.
J'aimerais qu'on arrête de d'être
content ou en tout cas pas si on n'est
pas content en tout cas de se de trouver
une tolérable qui est 25 % de nos jeunes
qui soient au chômage chez nous, 40 à 45
% des pays de d'Europe du Sud.
J'aimerais qu'on arrête de mettre de
côté notre jeunesse et je voudrais qu'on
puisse dire à notre jeunesse qu'elle
elle a le droit. Elle doit, elle peut
continuer à rêver et que le monde lui
appartient.
Tu viens ce weekend ?
Ça va être un peu compliqué ce weekend
mais une autre fois avec plaisir.
Isabelle Saporta. Merci.
Merci.
[Musique]